Hey, what's up. I'm Logan, Paul, and I'm here to answer the internet.
[Inaudible].
You can fight one person to the death and switch lives with them. If you win,
who would you fight Bieber
coming for you Bieber. I want your life Bieber. I want to wear it.
I want to wear that skinnier as Bieber was good dog.
Would you rather orgasm every time you hear all star by smash mouth or hear
all-star every time you orgasm. Whew. That's a,
that's a smash song and it almost be like a dope soundtrack to
my sex life. So definitely I'd love to hear all star every time I Oregon.
Ooh.
What's the grossest thing you've ever Snapchatted. This is bad.
I sent my mom a new dog. No, but hold up. It's it's there's an asterix.
I put an emoji over my, uh, penis. Was it intentional?
Yes.
Come loudly.
Every time you fart or fart loudly. Every time you come.
Come on.
Yo. Uh, coming, coming is dope,
but so as far ding.
So if you could do both at once pro com com loudly every time you fart.
That's cool. That's tight. Who writes these questions?
Would you rather a goat? And nobody knows, or you don't go,
but everybody thinks you're dead. No, I've heard this before.
Oh man. I've thought about this one. I don't think,
I don't think I could ever a go.
I couldn't like I'm cool with everyone thinking I a goat.
That's fine with me, dude. Like, come on. I've done some weird.
Like everyone thinks I have a micro penis, but that one's true.
Would you rather, every time you laugh, a dog dies. Every time you fall in love.
There's a genocide.
What is sick question?
Oh no, no, no, no. I know the answer I hear. Here's the deal.
It's so bad.
I love my dog lives and I love laughing.
So I don't think I could kill a dog every time I laughed. But, uh,
it and I fall in love a few times, dude. Like,
so probably the genocide is bad as it's like, Oh no, wait, stop everyone.
Stop please. No, it's not like that. I mean, just I'm like,
I don't fall in love often if ever like you're safe.
Some country or large group of people is safe.
Would you rather lose a leg or never have sex? Again? Get rid of the like,
the leg. I don't need my legs. Both of them.
Would you rather suck one Dick for 50 K. Okay.
Would you rather suck one Dick for 500 K or get five K for every Dickie suck.
Let's do like 550.
Would you rather suck one Dick for 50 K or get 5k for every Dick? You suck.
So I would have to suck 50.
Like I can make all the money then I'm I'm out of money I make is on me. Oh,
that's dope, man. I probably go with that one. Dick.
You can do a lot with half a million dollars. My. This question.
[Inaudible].
Would you rather be falsely accused of murder or never be able to stop coming?
Does that even make sense.
Man? Just to come, could get in the way of things I need to do.
So.
No, no, no. I make YouTube videos. No, bro. I make YouTube videos.
I don't need to like apply for jobs and. Like I can be blacklisted.
What's the weirdest thing you've masturbated to bro. Oh man.
Aye.
I used to have sex with my body pillow bro. Shut up. Everyone did don't lie.
No, come on, dude. Everyone like a couch cushion bro.
I definitely you're the weird one. I
don't say that.
Every, every pre pubescent, teenage boy, adolescent, adolescent lad,
you a couch and you think that's cool. Don't outta here bro.
You're a weirdo starting today. If you get $10,000 a day for every day,
you don't. How many days could you go without jerking off? Forever. Forever.
Literally forever bro. I be, I be chilling. Yeah, I'll be my,
my libido has been low dude. All I do is grind. I don't even like sex.
Would you rather sit on like would you rather sit on a cake and eat a Dick
or sit on a Dick and eat a cookie
Who's who's who's I let's let me let's preface this. Who's providing the Dick.
Like where does one? Just have a Dick available for consumption. I choose who,
whose Dick it is. Oh, that's tight.
I probably sit on the cake and eat the Dick, but who's they would've been bro.
Oh, wait, will you sit on a Dick? Is, is the Dick is a flacid? No.
So that's the appeal of not sitting on the deck? I feel it. I feel it.
I don't know if I, I don't know if I be cool with that one.
If every time you finished sex, a song played,
which song would you want it to be? Eye of the tiger for sure.
I have the tag and I can just cheer and run around the room. I've done that.
I'm not even kidding. I've done that. My ex hated me for it. I'd play.
We are the champs.
Oh man. No, no.
You know what song I play aloe black.
I'm the man that you can go and tell everybody. Yeah,
I hate myself. Next question.
Would you punch your grandmother in the face to the girl of your dreams?
Oh my God. Hey
and Joanne, I love you, grandma, grandma. Joanne. I love you.
But I would knock you the out.
Cold cold.
The one cartoon character you would bang.
The first one that comes to mind honestly, is the Tasmanian devil.
That is a spinner.
Quite literally, quite literally.
I had to wear one mascot head during sex for the rest of your life.
Which one would you choose?
I don't know why.
That's what I'm saying. So the first thing came to my mind was a lobster and I,
and I don't know why I that's why?
Cause on the Amanda show way back in the day, I might be dating myself here,
but she'd say bring in the dancing lobsters. I always thought they were so hot.
If you were dating a 10,
but at nighttime she turned into a hideous creature like Fiona from Shrek.
Would you still date her? Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely.
Absolutely. Also I have pink eye. Can you tell,
okay. I just looked at the camera and like I felt that one,
I was a little smaller. I'm like absolutely.
Would you date a girl knowing all of her previous exes are dead.
Oh, probably not. No.
You gotta think like probably not black window type thing.
For sure. She's for sure. She's black widow, bro. For sure. She's black.
She kills him and sucks the power out of there. I can't do that.
I don't want any.
That smoke.